I am in therapy I am in therapy I am in
therapy I'm in therapy I'm in therapy
I'm in therapy all right
all right let's talk about trauma
are we trauma dumping
what if we started like this what if we
all talk about maybe when we started
therapy how many therapists we've seen
probably and then can we end it with
something that we're grateful for sure I
love that uh her name's Franco I've been
in therapy for about a year and a half
I'm grateful to just be a better
Communicator just because of Any you
know just able to talk properly not just
throwing my emotions out I've been in
therapy since 2019 which would be
sophomore year for me in high school
I've actually only had one and I feel
really really lucky for that but my dad
is a therapist and my mom is like a
counselor and so they were able to find
me a therapist in sophomore year I was a
little suspicious because like oh his
parents or therapists as a natural young
man you're rebellious against your
parents that would already make me not
like therapy at all I've been going to
therapy for about four years now I think
the beautiful thing about therapy is
like you have the option to choose
what's best suited for you you shouldn't
just like give up on it and right now
I'm currently working with a therapist
we talk every Wednesday and it's been
like phenomenal we've been with each
other for almost a year now I love it
I'm Cameron I've been doing uh therapy
for about two years I went through two
one was a school therapist and so I
found another therapist outside of
school and he's been fantastic so I've
been working with him for about two
years I'm Marcus I've been going to
therapy now officially I'd say a little
over nine months so it's still new-ish
it's an easy excuse for a mole to be
like I've only been in therapy for not
that long so I might not have all the
terminology or the ability and the
skills to express myself and have the
conversation I'm Beth and I've been in
therapy for six months now I am on my
first therapist and things have been
going great the thing that I was looking
for was a gay man of color just because
they
have that they just understand the
culture and kind of what we have we've
all been through I'm Gerardo I
started therapy probably when I was in
Middle School but it was very on and off
and I guess what what I've struggled
with is just like you guys said I think
finding someone who could resonate with
your Life Path is really what I'm
looking for and I think with my current
therapist you also have to put in the
work and be honest like I think that's a
key thing too like you can't if you lie
to your therapist they can help you I'm
realizing that part of it is putting in
the work myself and being able to be
honest with my therapist and at first we
don't really vibing but we're starting
to get each other hey good humans it's
John we want to thank better help for
sponsoring this portion of today's video
better help is the world's largest
therapy service and it's 100 online with
better help you can tap into a network
of over 25 000 licensed and experienced
therapists who can help you with a wide
range of issues to get started all you
need to do is answer a few questions
about your needs and preferences in
therapy that way it better help can
match you with the right therapist from
their Network then you can talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom pick for you or
scheduling flexibility and a more
affordable price check out the link in
the description below get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com Jubilee
media that's betterhelp.com Jubilee
media thanks again better help for
sponsoring this episode now let's get
back to the video
[Music]
finding out that he has family that is
in the therapy profession I was like
that's a little convenient
I came in here and I was like all right
there's probably two strategies if I was
a mole I would be either leading the
conversation or really quiet I'd
probably do what he's doing if I was a
mole
oh boy
the tie is between vet
and Cirrus
I started therapy to help me work
through some traumatic experiences that
I went through in early High School I
believe the type of therapy that my
therapist specializes in is called
narrative therapy he has me kind of walk
through my experiences that I went
through and then he helps me like shift
my perspective on them away from while
this was this horrible thing that
happened to me specifically with dealing
with things that happened in early High
School band I've been seeing him for two
and a half years so so since starting
therapy I've learned a bunch of
different coping mechanisms
one of the things that brought me into
therapy was abusing alcohol and I'm
going through kind of just
the very beginning stages of learning
different mental disorders like ADHD and
starting to work with the psychiatrists
and everything
[Music]
[Applause]
I guess we could talk about like reasons
that we went into therapy
um so around
um 2016 there was a motorcycle accident
that took the life of one of my closest
friends from the Marine Corps obviously
with the military let's prolong use of
alcohol so like that's never an easy
thing to deal with I was like okay if I
don't get help now I'm about to
self-sabotage and literally like we
probably we wouldn't even be having this
conversation yeah so I went about two
years ago I started going uh it started
off with like I got out of a
relationship that was uh pre it
shouldn't have been really brutal but it
really was brutal on me and then I kind
of I realized that all the relationships
around me were the same as that and so
they're all Hollow and so I realized I
was looking at other people to get value
from them as men too I don't know how
you guys feel but it's kind of taught
that we're not supposed to feel and then
we learn how to suppress our emotions I
always thought I was a people pleaser
but I know I've also hurt people I have
a substance abuse problem and I like to
say hurt people hurt people but healed
people heal people he sounded so
scripted not saying that what he says
wasn't genuine but it just sounded so
rehearsed that I was like okay that
might be something no I definitely agree
with you you know especially like in the
Black Culture you know it's a stigma for
us so just even talk about like our
emotions like we we mask a lot of our
emotions and humor because that's just
how like we talk about stuff but you
know especially myself being military
it's like I've got like three whammys
against me it's like military black man
yeah we need to talk about the stuff for
sure
you seem too animated like maybe he's
trying to convince me that he's not the
mole
no
damn guys you did me dirty that's okay
it's okay all love all love
if you think the mole is still in the
box and you'd like to continue the game
raise your hand
yeah
going back to the aspect of being a
people pleaser like at a certain point I
kind of lost what my identity was and so
I was just like I would kind of blend
into whatever anybody needed at that
point in time yeah yeah and so I just
wasn't processing that I wasn't looking
after myself at all or what I wanted
like I thought oh you know I gotta get
married have kids because that's what
you do and then I like ask myself why do
I want that and it's like because my
parents did that that could potentially
be a strategy too is kind of get kind of
lost in the noise type attitude so I was
like okay if I was a mole that could be
easy to find a lie in there I feel you a
hundred percent on that I'm like I'm in
my 30s that's another relationship down
for x amount of time it's like and my
parents never pressure me to get married
or have children I always put the
pressure on myself never so like even
just trying to deal with that when
therapy is like something to talk about
right now I resonate so heavily with
what you're saying about being whoever
you need to be for the people around you
that's been the biggest thing for me
lately is figuring out how to put my own
needs first so hard so it's exhausting
they become a pillar of your life and
then that pillar gets ripped out and
then you fall you know right
I noticed as
our therapy session was going along he
kind of pulled back
honestly at that point I was just
grasping for straws I'm not even gonna
lie to you
[Applause]
all right boys
you're good yeah if you think the mole
is still in the box and you want to
continue the game raise your hand
I feel like we got the person out but
like
yeah I feel like and I can let it go
yeah I feel like I trust all of your
stories and I relate to all your stories
a lot so yeah all right cool so we
decided we're gonna end it yeah we can
call it we're gonna end it if the lights
turn green that means that you have
voted the mole out and you all win if
the lights turn red that means the mole
is still in the box and you lose
three
two one
I trust too easily
sometimes it's good to have trust issues
go with your gut
will the mole reveal themselves in three
two
one
um
your Poker Face is absolutely amazing
thank you so almost everything I said
was true my whole story everything my
parents or therapists my I I have seen a
therapist before my guess was that like
once you said that your parents were
therapists that gave me sort of like a
suspicion I'm like maybe he just knows
certain terminologies because
it does it has yeah and I I really
appreciate all the conversations we've
had though before Oh yeah this was
really awesome like it's light-hearted
it's fun if we're gonna take anything
from this is that like you know what
like men can be vulnerable and can share
and not one at one point in time that I
feel judged or chastised yeah for any
for anything that I said why do you
think some men are still hesitant to go
to therapy I'm a huge proponent for
therapy for everyone I think I think
it's really important for a lot of
people and I think it is a really
helpful resource and I think we need to
work to destigmatize it say one last
thing absolutely real quick
um because I feel like I got I have a
responsibility to use this platform and
I also with the story I was telling you
about with the gentleman that died in
the motorcycle accident I actually keep
a bracelet with his name on here his
name's uh Lance corporal Malik Andre
Baxter so I gotta you know take this
time to send my love to his family and
to all the people in my old unit who
have either taken their lives or have
lost their lives through unfortunate
circumstances so this is for you guys oh
my God
you'll pay for my therapy